this is a destroyed turret gun of a
russian tank it was blown off the
vehicle and landed in the second story
of a house in ukraine
images from the war show many tanks
ending up with this type of damage
in some cases the top of the vehicle
flies a significant distance away we're
getting so much video of these tank
losses
it's really very illustrative of what's
happening in ways that was just
invisible in other wars
tanks play a crucial role in ground
warfare and as the world's second
largest exporter of military equipment
russian-made vehicles are used in
countries including india iran and
algeria
but hundreds have been destroyed during
the war with ukraine and what military
analysts say could be the biggest loss
of russian tanks since world war ii it's
going to be the better part of a decade
before they're actually able to get
their force back to where they were
the ongoing war has put this
vulnerability on public display
complicating russia's campaign in
ukraine and its production of tanks
[Music]
while moscow hasn't said how many of its
tanks have been destroyed since the
start of the war at least 440 have been
documented by oryx blog an open source
military equipment tracker more than
half of these are the same type of tank
to understand why we need to look at
their design
the t72 was first produced in 1969 with
many design iterations since one of its
most distinctive features is also a
vulnerability
this is the auto loading mechanism it
reduces the crew from four to three
members by removing the person
responsible for loading the main gun
most of the ammunition for this
autoloader is stored in the carousel a
kind of metal basket that the gunner
sits on top of the rest is often stored
in nooks and crannies around the inside
of the tank
having these elements stacked on top of
each other saves space within the t72
and gives it a low profile
it makes it much harder to see from the
side makes it harder to hit
william albert is a director at the
london-based think tank the
international institute for strategic
studies
he studied arms control and disarmament
for more than two decades
early tanks tended to be
relatively tall things would be
relatively easy for a soldier with an
anti-tank missile to take it out from a
distance because the higher it is you
know you can hit the turret from from
quite a ways away
the compact design has made the t72 a
cost effective and popular tank with
thousands used by militaries around the
world
but this design comes with a drawback
what military analysts call the jack in
the box effect that can happen when the
explosive material makes its way into
the tank usually through the turret ring
in a t-72 this sparks a chain reaction
the fire sets off the spare ammunition
sword around the inside of the tank
which in turn sets off the rest that's
stored underneath the crew if the hatch
is sealed the resulting explosion is
pressurized underneath the turret and
this video filmed by a chinese
television crew in ukraine shows what
can happen next
gas builds up the explosive builds up
and it sends the turrets sky high
sometimes meters high
modern western tanks like the american
m1 abrams have avoided this design
instead storing ammunition behind an
armored wall in the back
this design makes it taller and easier
to hit but if the ammunition is set off
it has a safer outlet and so the
ammunition goes out the back of the
turret and doesn't kill the crew and
they used to make us watch videos and
things like that just to reassure us
that that was the case
jeffrey edmonds served in the us army
for more than 20 years with tours in
iraq and afghanistan he's now a research
scientist with the center for naval
analysis a non-profit organization that
provides research for the u.s military
edmond says the t-72's weaknesses were
amplified by russia's strategy for how
the tanks were deployed in ukraine
footage released by the ukrainian
military shows russian tanks striving in
convoys towards kiev you don't just
drive tanks down roads and columns
when there's a threat of anti-tank
missiles or mines or things of that
nature this initial push left the
vehicles exposed to ukrainian soldiers
armed with thousands of high-powered
missiles that have been effective at
triggering the jack-in-the-box effect
when you look at the modern javelin type
weapons or the in-laws you have
basically the explosion coming from the
top and typically tanks have very little
protection on the top and so when that
happens that's the second way you could
you could get explosive material inside
the crew compartment that can set the
ammunition off
but as the war has shifted away from
urban centers towards the donbass region
of the country battles are now taking
place on open fields giving russia's
tanks more of an advantage the fight in
the east is a different fight it's
characterized much more by artillery
duels and that's why i think the
ukrainians are are suffering more
casualties now than they did at the
beginning
russia's ministry of defense didn't
respond to a request for comment about
the design of its tanks or how they were
deployed
ukraine has also been using the same
russian-made tanks the military analysts
say it's seen comparatively fewer losses
in part by attempting to minimize the
tank's vulnerabilities
in some cases that means going in with
um
fewer rounds
and not storing as much of the powdered
charges inside haphazardly within the
tank that the russians are
all this could create challenges for
russia's weapons industry the
vulnerabilities of the t-72 are being
displayed to tank operators in other
countries watching what's happening in
ukraine
it's got to be a little bit terrifying
now to be you know a tanker in a country
that has 272s and to think
that you are
stepping into a system
whose design choice was that if the tank
is hit tough western sanctions have also
limited russia's access to microchips
and advanced circuitry stifling their
capacity to develop and produce newer
tanks and missiles i think that's going
to continue being a problem for their
more advanced systems and with
everything else happening with with you
know young tech savvy people leaving
sanctions you know the economic downturn
mid to long term
it's pretty bleak